was für ein Chaos heute ist der erste
Tag an dem wir endlich auf unserem neuen
Hof wohnen Umzug es geschafft zumindest
sind jetzt alle unsere Möbel und Sachen
hier aber ausgepackt haben wir noch gar
nicht und ja ja darum kümmern wir uns
gleich aber erstmal müssen wir hier
Prioritäten setzen mein Freund hat diese
unglaublich leckeren Pfifferlinge
gefunden also gehen wir mal in den
Garten und gucken was wir da leckeres
zum Kochen finden Karotte und die
Kartoffeln haben wir gekauft und das ist
für mich ein ganz ungewohntes Gefühl
weil wir durch den Umzug mitten im
Sommer keinen wirklichen Gemüsegarten
haben dieses Jahr wird aber jetzt über
den Herbst und Winter einen neuen
Gemüsegarten hier am Hof anlegen und
dann haben wir spätestens nächsten
Sommer wieder jedes erdenkliche Gemüse
aus dem eigenen Selbstversorger Garten
nicht Teile hier alle unsere Garten und
hofabenteuer also wenn ihr sowas
spannend findet dann seid gerne mit
dabei